magic to me is the feeling that you get
Christmas Eve when Santa Claus comes to
your home and delivers presents but and
the smile on children's faces when the
rabbit suddenly appears they know that's
magic it's my passion it's my hobby it's
my vocation it's everything to me
welcome to : Michigan the magic capital
of the world I am John Stehr Lanie the
owner of sterling magic manufacturing my
name is Rick Fisher I'm the president
and CEO of the fab magic company I am
Greg Bordner and I am the president of
Abbott's magic and I brought a good book
with me it's called the Bible sometimes
there's some really cool parts in here
there's really some fire and brimstone
there are three magic shops in :
Michigan and we're about three blocks
apart directly next to me is fab magic
and Abbot's magic is located one block
west of us there's a lot of little
things here in : there are top hats in
the street with flowers blooming in them
we have one pizza parlor we have two gas
stations we only have one blinking light
we have a magicians walk of fame it's
kind of like our very own Hollywood Walk
of Fame our high school mascot is the
Fighting Magi there's the magic city
hardware there's illusions hair care and
we have three magic shops all in a town
of 1,200 people I'll share this with you
if colon was any smaller they'd call it
semi colon bad joke yes bad joke Abbot's
magic began doing the magic convention
80 some years ago we've had thousands of
magicians from around the world that
gather here to learn to share their
their knowledge of magic
when you perform a magic trick and a
little kids smiles and he goes wow you
can see the magic in his face that's
really the best part before that 15 20
minutes our you hopefully took that
person from this world to this world I
always said to my parents even as a
young kid I'm gonna move up here one of
these days and I'm gonna own a magic
shop they do come true